married to the beautiful and talented
kyra sedgwick who i've met many times
the honor of talking to her you guys
great marriage all these years did you
guys was she sold on you right away when
you first met oh god no no no young and
she first met you she no she was very
young she was 22 I think when we first
met her 9:23 and I we were working
together we were in Boston right that's
where we met and fell in love and you
know the things that she didn't she
thought it was very cocky she thought I
was like kind of you know full of myself
were you a little absolutely yeah I was
a complete [ __ ] I mean just just
really Scott you know it shocked me that
she hadn't seen all my work for instance
yeah I mean why would she yeah I mean I
remember saying to her something about
Footloose and she had never seen foot
lesson obviously you're kidding me I
didn't even think she was telling me the
truth
but the but what's funny is that it was
that but it was also certain things
about me that she just didn't dig I had
this coat it was a green coat I remember
and it was made out of wool and I had a
Labrador which it wasn't really a
Labrador
it was a mutt it was a black mutt and I
had the the coat and the dog with me and
she thought those two things were just
so assholey
yeah she was like and she's told me in
retrospect it's like that you had that
coat and you had the dog and what was
the dog a real dick about no no
soccer good yeah yeah I mean a dog
should be okay but the real troll thing
yeah you're a real [ __ ] dog yeah that
was a very nice dog never bitter she
shan't fall in love with the dog and you
know we had the dog for another you know
15 years or something but night it was
just something that she felt like maybe
I was using it as a prop which you
probably were